war comes suddenly
and it comes from the sky
a loud blast and everything that was
once the comfort of home
now gone
for the elderly limited in movement
many can't make it down to the
underground shelter of this nine-story
building
rescue workers pick up parts of what
used to be ordinary lives in kiev
it's hard to comprehend what is
happening here
it is a city he is just a jerk a total
jerk i've got nothing else to say
you see i've got no words to describe it
this war is now into its third week
military analysts may be assessing that
russia's advance is slow but it is
deadly
humanitarian corridors have been agreed
upon for monday and more aid convoys are
planned
we will again try to unblock the
movement of the humanitarian convoy from
bodhiansk to marriott
the port city of marrapal remains under
a devastating siege attempts to move
civilians out has failed day after day
people may remember this heavily
pregnant mother being rescued following
a russian strike on a maternity hospital
last week
news now emerging that she and her baby
have died
on the day when the maternity hospital
was hit three women were brought here
one was in critical condition with a
crushed pelvis and a detached hip while
we were resuscitating her
and
carried out a cesarean section and took
out her lifeless child
more than 30 minutes of resuscitation
didn't produce any results then more
than 30 minutes of resuscitation of the
mother didn't produce results both died
but new life is also bringing joy here
despite being born into an uncertain
future
these are terrifying days
but there is defiance here and the
uncompromising will to survive
the war is never far away
the mental toll unbearable in a city
under bombardment
nowhere feels safe
talks between both sides are expected on
monday
russia says ukraine needs to compromise
for the war to end but for now the army
the president and countless civilians
across the country who have taken up
arms to defend their nation and their
future refuse to do so
stephanie decker al-jazeera